would you buy clothes that don't exist
and how much would you be willing to pay
earlier this year benoit pakoto's design
studio artifact worked with teenage
digital artist ferocious to sell 620
pairs of virtual sneakers
generating a total of 3.1 million
dollars in less than five minutes i'm
not looking at the fashion history to be
inspired or looking at gaming anime
sci-fi movies that that's our reference
points
entrepreneurs in the space say that one
day virtual fashion will become
ubiquitous
the first step is understanding how the
blurring of physical and digital worlds
will change our definition of what's
real we have one consciousness right i
mean i can read twitter
and get pissed off i don't get digital
pissed off we kind of need to let go of
this notion of kind of oh that's digital
this is physical
we've all been increasingly living in
something called the metaverse
the metaverse is nothing but the
internet breaking kind of free from the
two-dimensional barrier into this
three-dimensional environment and then
when it starts blurring more and more
with our daily life and our daily life
becomes enhanced then that's what we see
as the metaverse
if it sounds a bit like science fiction
to you then you're on the right track
the dematerialization of fashion is here
and it's going to change the fashion
business as we know it
what we wear says a lot about who we are
yet fashion is also a 2.5 trillion
dollar global industry that touches
everyone on earth
i'm imran ahmed i first started trying
to make sense of the fashion business 15
years ago as it was being transformed by
technology globalization and shifting
consumer values
now i'm on a journey to see how fashion
is recalibrating amid the pandemic to
balance profit with purpose
this is the business of fashion show
join me to see how fashion shapes
business culture and identity
and to meet the people forging fashion's
future
[Music]
as the world stayed home during the
pandemic there was still somewhere to go
to get dressed up
[Music]
welcome to the metaverse
the term may come from science fiction
but the business opportunities in this
fast evolving convergence of digital and
physical worlds are real
the metaverse has grown out of gaming
where players already spend over 100
billion dollars a year on virtual goods
3 billion people more than a third of
the world's population
regularly play video games
46 of gamers are women
and across generations people prefer
video games over movies and tv shows
making gaming the world's leading form
of entertainment
[Music]
dressing avatars has come a long way
from battleground beginnings as gaming
emerges as a lucrative channel for
luxury brands to reach new customers
screenware is the new streetwear
a growing trend in this new fashion
space
matching real-life purchases with a
digital twin
new breed creatives make playful
tributes to their favorite brands
real world cities embrace virtual
fashion shows
and virtual department stores
so don't write this off as a blip it's a
game changer
and we cannot yet know where it might go
[Music]
demand for one-off nfts unique certified
digital assets is soaring
in fashion nfts are the couture of the
metaverse where the unfettered creations
of digital artisans can outprice those
of global brands and hyped assets driven
by scarcity are crypto status symbols
the upside
measurable planetary savings production
of a digital garment emits 97 less co2
than a physical one
the downside
minting and mining nfts requires
skyrocketing energy consumption in the
real world
the shift to more environmentally
efficient methods can't come fast enough
yet virtual fashion facilitates the
expression of multiple selves in a
virtual world where brands recreate the
experiences that define fashion culture
while not forgetting our eternal joy of
getting dressed up in real life
[Music]
paris is the global capital of fashion
and virtual fashion is no exception as
the city sets its sights on becoming
more technology focused
my first stop is to meet with ian rogers
who moved to paris from silicon valley
in 2015 when he was appointed chief
digital officer of lvmh
acting as a kind of digital whisperer to
c-suite executives of more than 75
luxury brands
[Music]
welcome the avenue merci
now ian is chief experienced officer of
ledger whose security technology helps
customers protect their crypto assets
using bespoke hardware and software ian
is the perfect person to explain
what exactly is an nft anyway
so i was a part of a company in the late
90s called nullsoft that made an mp3
player called winamp but this is
actually
the image of an nft that i bought on
the website foundation
on the blockchain the art only has one
owner that's why it's a non-fungible
token correct so if you have a
photograph series where there's one two
three four five six seven nine ten it
matters if you have one of ten or two of
ten
on the other hand if i owe you twenty
dollars you don't care which twenty
dollars i give you right you just want
twenty dollars worth of value right so
non-fungible means
it's gotta be the one so this is a one
of one of uh a winamp tribute art which
yes is displayed on a screen in my
living room and how much did it cost
i spent
1.137
each on it
which eth is a digital currency correct
so that's ethereum ian is uniquely
positioned to give us foundational
knowledge about the opportunities
created as crypto technologies gaming
and fashion converge
fashion plays such a big role
in
helping people express their identity
and if lots of people
are starting to spend
a lot of time in virtual spaces
it seems natural then that they could
use
fashion as a vehicle for expressing
their identity
in those spaces does that make sense to
you i think 100 i think it's inevitable
i think that this is a generational
shift and i look at my 14 year old and
she has spent the last year and a half
living in a metaverse she doesn't even
know that word right but her school is
on zoom
she hangs out with her friends online in
one form or another actually in a whole
bunch of different forms right in
instagram in tik tok in imessage in
in fortnite in um animal crossing in
uh you know in all of these different
you know metaverses right um and so for
them
having a digital collection
it's completely natural look what
happened to us even you know with with
photographs we used to take photographs
and and you know have them developed and
hang them up in our homes and there were
many companies that thought oh this
digital camera thing like who wants that
right most kids don't even have physical
photos right they only have collections
of digital photos and so i think that
you could expect the same thing with
many physical things why would i want a
collection of stuff that no one can see
when i can have a collection of digital
stuff that everyone can see i think for
a younger generation this is just going
to become kind of natural and obvious do
you see you know big
luxury fashion brands and fashion brands
generally do you see them
in the foreseeable future getting into
the place where they're just selling
virtual goods i think they will but to
be honest i think it's a mistake i would
wait longer um if i were them i think
it's inevitable but i think that you
know the reason that nfts have taken off
at the beginning of this year is because
we have these nft marketplaces you know
if you don't have a place to display
these things then it doesn't exist so i
think that the progression is more going
to be
that we start to get i that's why i say
i'm excited about the things that happen
at scale where we start to get you know
a collection
of um digital goods with our physical
goods we then start to take those into
our metaverse worlds so i think that
once i can take that digital shoe
and it changes my character in fortnight
ah now the dominoes start to fall and
now
you can sell me a digital good only
right but you need that second piece you
need the place for it to live in the
digital world before
it's really exciting to sell a virtual
piece so i think that if i'm a brand
there's only downside in selling digital
pieces right now because either it
doesn't sell for enough money and that's
a bad story or it sells for too much
money and then it's worth less next year
and that's a bad story where if i just
work on getting digital with physical at
scale
the other side of that marketplace will
show up and now digital goods will make
sense what is the underlying
instinct or
emotion that leads someone to value
something that they can't touch
as human beings we have some innate
desire to sort of prove we existed and
those things really happened to us you
know i think that the digital collectors
today it's so early
they're speculators you know but
there are you know like in art there are
people who see something before anyone
else
um and i think that any time that you
give creative people when you give a
creative community a canvas
it's just a matter of time until they
blow your mind
but how will we buy virtual fashion
to understand that question i consult
with the co-founders of the d
materialized
a berlin-based digital fashion startup
they explain how the lines between
physical and digital realities are
blurring
so we like to think of the d materialise
as the digital department store of your
dreams it's not like a regular
online shop it's something different
it's something that takes you into
another space another dimension through
what it looks like basically say i buy
something on dematerialized to wear in
the metaverse
how do i put it on
and show it off and experience it well
they're different avenues so the first
thing is you could wear it on your real
self through an ar filter so that's
number one and that's the part where
technology is still you know working
progress it's going to get better and
better we know it but still you know the
fidelity won't look like
you right now it will look like you're
digitally enhanced but it's a lot of fun
we can also do like a bespoke fitting in
which you get dressed by a digital
tailor
correct or you could take it into a
computer game so right now we have
optimized it for a couple of computer
games and then you could take it there
and wear it in your avatar clothes are a
very physical thing right so why would
anyone want to buy a digital
dress i think it takes us back to that
the materializations of goods that we've
been seeing since we have digital
technologies that it comes from the
gaming world effectively in which your
avatar is part of your personalities so
i think as we regular people start
transitioning more and more into the
virtual world spending more time in
virtual environments and that that
barrier between physical and digital
starts learning more and more and we
will start consuming you know digital
fashion digital sneakers digital makeup
digital jewelry
as well i mean i think effectively is
the biggest revolution the fashion
industry have seen so far one of the
criticisms about digital is that it's
impersonal or people don't think that
it's real and we create very emotional
experiences the fashion in itself
looks quite unreal so
you could have a dress which is on fire
or a dress which is made of water and
that kind of instantly pulls
the user in to say okay this is
different this is different to what i've
seen before on a screen
say i have created
a dress
and this was printed all over my digital
dress how does someone buy it can you
walk me through it we're working really
hard in making that battery of entry for
regular consumers super low because
right now purchasing an nft or any
crypto asset per se
can be a bit complicated and you need to
understand how certain pieces of the
technology work you need to be able to
set up a wallet
potentially have ether in your wallet in
order to move your nfts in the future so
we're trying to minimize all of that
complexity to the bare minimum so they
can manage the ownership in a very
simple way without having to understand
how the whole crypto world works
[Music]
now i'm on my way to meet someone who
has collaborated closely with karina and
marjorie
benoit pagato is one of the brilliant
new creative entrepreneurs shaping
digital fashion a gamer at heart he's
the man behind one of the most lucrative
nft drops to date
a fine arts graduate and branding expert
benoit runs artifact studios out of
paris
but it was born in the metaverse
i was always a gamer and i always
believed that game were the
most
innovative and amazing medium you could
have and so that's why i think we're
leaving this moment where i think i'm
very very lucky because
all the stuff i grew up with i can
combine all this knowledge together now
to make something i i truly genuinely
know
how to do it because it's just combining
all of this stuff i've been learning and
you know being passionate about for a
year so artifact is a blueprint of the
brand of the future that's evolving in a
world where gaming is the main cultural
reference artifact in a way is like a
digital atelier
yeah in a sense because when you do 3d
and when you do game game assets or
virtual items there's a lot of
craftsmanship going into it it's a it's
a lot of traditional crafts you can just
do virtually so it's sculpting modelling
texturing so it's a lot of things you
can find as well in traditional fashion
because you have the small hand
you know
so it is a there's a sense of
craftsmanship in everything we do so
it's in a sense it's a natural year
workshop you sold
3.1 million dollars of virtual sneakers
in something like under 10 minutes five
minutes yeah five minutes
can you like walk us through the process
to create that and then how
you took it to market we love sneaker
culture and we think it's the
fashion item that is the most you know
culturally broad it's touching everyone
you know whether you're a kid from the
streets or you know every high fashion
brand is you know going ham on sneakers
as well
and and ferocious i detected him
on twitter and i contacted him and i
said hey like like do you want to make
sneakers uh and so it's he said it was
his dream since he's a child that one
day make a pair of sneakers all the
designs were done in a week i think
then we put everything back in 3d to
show him how it would look like before
making physicals
because the goal was always to sell the
sneakers as digital first but for people
to have later on a tangible you know
reward of having the nft which is the
this relationship
so that's how it happened everything was
done in the lapse of two weeks
from the design to the content to the
lunch
it was really two weeks
we were all surprised that we never
expected to make as much
and it happened in five minutes so it
was funny because we were just all
watching the numbers and seeing everyone
buying and then we took our calculators
i mean we just made three million
dollars
but
really everyone was surprised and i
think the really really great thing was
that we
we are a new brand uh we used
digital sneakers first as a way to
launch a product and we did that with 18
years old artist that
no one knew and we completely changed
the game how you can think of releasing
a fashion item or releasing a drop of
sneakers so that's i think the impact is
gonna be much bigger than the three
million dollars the really interesting
part was the process of how we did it
and
and how we we managed to completely i
think make history at this time that
still today people are making it a
reference of
remember that sneaker drop that sold out
in five minutes for three million
dollars the nft itself is like a
like a subscription service to have
exclusive access
only if you have that item you can have
access to these extra experiences or
products we're gonna release
artifact is at the forefront of luxury
nfts and being a first mover has its
advantages
in april 2021 benoit and his co-founders
raised an 8 million funding round led by
andreessen horowitz one of silicon
valley's most storied venture capital
firms tell me a little bit about the
reaction from investors silicon valley
does not have a reputation for
understanding fashion nothing in our
business is linked to the legacy
business of fashion and andrey scenarios
have been very active in investing in
very very cool new innovative game
studios and actually they invested from
the gaming fund in us
so that's why i think they understood
very well that the world of gaming and
fashion we're merging but there's very
very few people we can actually put it
together and make that bridge and make
something that is
culturally impactful and you know
successful as well and find the product
market feed
and us we demonstrated product market
fit with you know millions of dollars
you mentioned the fomo from the fashion
brands when they call you
what are they asking you about what you
know what are they trying to learn
how can we learn from you what can we do
together some of them they were just
really trying to fish for information
for free
and we detected that very very early
it's a culture they are not
understanding and you can't understand
it from one day to the other so they
need to hire the right people i think
it's really a hr problem they're gonna
have
and second is just that yeah it's in any
case at best it's gonna be their
innovation team
taking care of it and
honestly i mean i don't didn't meet all
of them but i i didn't see innovation
coming from fashion brands in a long
time
virtual fashion is clearly a space to
watch but for now it only attracts a
niche crowd
how long will it take before the full
vision becomes reality at scale
you know i i think it's just the case
where the storytelling gets ahead of the
reality so this is exactly what caused
you know the dot-com bubble in the late
90s you know
and the excitement was real and it was
deserved you know the internet has
changed humanity it just you know the
storytelling i think got a little bit
ahead of the reality there was more work
to do before
all these things were built up and i
think it's the same here you know people
want to kind of fast forward to the end
um but a you can't see the end
b this technology is still really
nascent you know the way that we do
something like nft is it's not very
mature i think we will see a lot of
power players emerging
from completely different prices
decentralizing the powers within the
fashion industry there might be an
amazing designer in kenya and is 13
years old if she or he gets his hands on
a computer and can enter the market then
we should be there to allow them to do
that the real application is going to be
once we have augmented reality glasses
and you'll be able to see these virtual
garments everywhere and you know
buy them or see who's get an expensive
nft based fashion item that's when
augmented reality glasses will be
mainstreamed
as we do already today we just like you
know use your phone with snapchat
filters and the technology
is still clunky but you can see it's
going there for sure that's when it's
really gonna start that big shift i
think towards
mainly buying digital items and physical
items being more just like very very
practical
comfortable
stuff that you can wear daily when you
spend most of your time in augmented
worlds
historically fashion has had a poor
track record in anticipating and
adapting to new technologies and
platform shifts
but this time around the big brands seem
to be moving faster whether they can
compete with the digitally native
entrepreneurs defining the space
well that remains to be seen
you